[Music]
and escape fail Musa do something
serious with that she came out hello
sexual submitted by I less than three JK
what's that mean no I started doing the
math my head what the [ __ ] he said
pac-man three stupid escaped inmates
were arrested at an escape room we're
just having fun
how ironic really were working they were
practicing but they escaped yet isn't
but then they were probably like what if
we go back let's let's let's keep our
escape if we can escape with jail let's
try to skip a dungeon when you escape
from jail aren't you supposed to lay low
as I say in the movies straight to
Mexico that's right
that's rather criminal if they don't
live there okay they move there because
it's paradise it's really cool what are
you gonna do with the money escape to
Mexico south of the border do they know
Mexico is an awesome country and
everybody Mexico so chill dude say what
you do for a living
everybody rapes in Mexico hey David I
love offended a whole country big egg
rolls yeah maybe for these guys they
thought that if they were to if they
were able to escape prison they can
escape anything no man they wanted to
test their skills yeah
they're practicing you know escape rules
will not let you record him there ya
know cuz then you give away all their
secrets I bet they change it up all the
time though that's why not all the time
they I think like they count the number
of escapes that's happened before they
change to look me like a hundred escapes
we know this that's like some
information to someone last time oh he
actually got inside information
how do you look like you can't just
google that have you guys done escape
loose no everyone wanted to Nikki and
fever wandering - doing with us forever
I did one two years ago I do more
recently oh how was it it was fine it
was like for Sean's birthday but your
friend Sean would not know I definitely
definitely remember inviting you guys
how could I forget my favorite Asian
American youtubers see it's right here I
circled it right there
Ryan cut back to the video go Ryan go
out of town or something no editor by
night I hadn't been out of town what's
the [ __ ] Sean I'm see each other every
day go or did you want to bond with your
baby Gio you said a few months ago right
now if you want to go as recently okay
yeah you too
you're off the hook shop yeah I don't I
don't like escape rooms cuz like have
you been no it's just like Yousaf I do
not cut is forced anxiety I don't like
that it's really fine it depends on what
kind of room you do cuz my brother I
think my brother don't leave Ami's are
some [ __ ] no no no it's a lot of house
yes see that oh so it's either [ __ ] but
there's also the Sherlock Holmes kind to
like mystery we did yeah and then I
think I Malaysia we did one too right we
did the that was like that was people's
body parts at all yeah I don't like that
because like there's the one that sound
what it's like you you know the when you
don't figure out zombies come in I'm
just go start swinging that people even
if they're paid actors one of the ones I
feel it's like medieval times based and
if there's this one or like there's this
code that's based off smell so if
there's like six bottles and you I
should have to smell I'm gonna have to
find the lavender one and the lavender
one and then like the whatever one if it
creates a combination and then you press
the right buttons and then like this big
ass don't being open what if what was
far it's really it's really some homes
know that he has hater blockers he would
never know oh so he would be the smell
cult guy yeah yeah okay it was fun
there's like some really fun which one
did you guys go - oh yeah yeah escape
room la maybe
okay I thought they were all like based
on death no not all of them yeah cuz I'm
cool with that cuz I don't like it like
anxiety situations the first one we did
though it had all these chopped up body
parts and it was kind of scary because
they had sound like they had the
creaking and then like it was subtle -
it wasn't loud where you knew was fake
it was like you heard people screaming
and dying in the other room yeah ii III
got scared whoa you you didn't get
scared I know
oh they should have a legit escape room
then if they're gonna do that
I'll just hey do you have that so I just
have like you're like you're in the room
with your friends and then you have a
naked like sexual predator with a
lollipop in a cage yeah it's it's like I
think we reported it here where it's
like it's like actual stimulation of
like someone's I try to like murder you
or and [ __ ] like that
yeah I think we did it [ __ ] murder you
yeah like it's really scary like it
really [ __ ] with you oh that's why I'm
saying like the sexual credit thing I
think that's gonna be the one that I did
there was an actor in there so like she
was like getting this cloak that's
covered and she just stood there and
then I'll tell you something was done
right she won't help but then like weird
so at first I thought was a mannequin
because you can't really see the face
then when we unlock something she went
follow me and she just start up that's a
scary job to have but then afterwards
you see her and then she has like
piercings in like like Hot Topic nail
polish and she's like the normal girl
how can we touched your rings you said a
hot topic now second piercings you know
like those girls these days with like a
turquoise strip and then a [ __ ]
septum [ __ ] bald boring and then like
one of those girls she looks organic she
looks fine well these girls Kelsey's 23
years old they're girls
[ __ ] bad-ass how come this online
white girls they are or they look like
they are uh so they ended up jumping the
fence at the Edmonton Institution Canada
and it's Canada yeah
Poland oh they jumped the fence when
they escaped around 8:40 p.m. wait so
the jail only had a fence can they
it is Canadia it's a it's a six-foot
fence it's a four foot rock so that just
in case you hop in like you don't hurt
yourself there's like a person that's
pretty close to there it looks like a
Nellie high school oh yeah that's true a
lot of people that come to LA say our
schools look like jails I know that's
true but um yeah so these women they
just jumped the fence they got away this
is on a Monday night about 8:40 p.m.
then the next day almost 24 hours later
or about 24 hours later Tuesday night
8:30 p.m. the pair they ended up at this
escape room called side-quests
adventures which is what it [ __ ] wait
the 24 out part it was really strange
because they went inside and then they
started asking the two owners like hey
what's in escape room or like how do you
play or whatever can we see one of your
room so then the woman what huh
what it's crazy do the that curious they
want like let's plan our getaway and
never get caught they're like oh [ __ ]
what's that how come they're Ella Valley
you're so crazy
Gabe don't why did a [ __ ] Samantha
and Cal say hey but that's a white
though yeah
we know somebody who's not from
California this talks like that you do
yeah not from Canada but they're not
nothing California that we know that
talks like a valley girl huh I don't
know but anyways girl so they went into
this escape room they started asking me
they were left I'll tell you guys later
and [ __ ] close your eyes trying to
tell these secrets let Tiffany comment
you're the one on their IG picture yes
then shortly after it while they were
looking at a room a cop went went into
this escape room asking my hated to
women walk into and that's when the guy
led the club to the room and they
started because they were playing they
were actually playing this gate room I
don't know trying to get away and hide
that's the weird thing like it seems
like they knew they were being followed
but then they went there or like why
didn't they run away the two girls with
a ball and chain on their ankle come in
here I'm gonna show you guys the video
of the escape room owner I thought they
were the two girls she's turning it I
was like oh the two girls is that that's
an Adam's apple I thought it was two
girls Hey don't assume the gender
I assume it by the [ __ ] an example
though that she's huge she's like a dick
on the throat oh here we go ladies come
down the stairs inquiring as to what we
did and what an escape room was all
about that's a pretty typical but these
were not your usual customers even if
they did look the part
Rebecca showed the pair around
explaining that an escape room provides
an adventure for teams who want to test
themselves against different puzzles
before time runs out the fugitive with
police arriving just minutes later
asking questions about the two women he
asked if they had appointments with us I
said
then he asked where they were very
shortly after they were cuffed and
walked straight out oh they're the worst
criminals ever well this one looks like
she smells
do they look related same facial
features like the nose and the mouth no
upper lip and missing eyebrow the cheeks
this one just looks so gross honey I
don't give a [ __ ] she looks like she's
sucking dicks in two dozen brush her
teeth she looks like the dr. Seuss
character she looks like such fish and
just leaves it yep she looks like an
oompa loompa witch doctor sister yeah
the main one or the Grinch no meetings
in Hamm wait what if I'm a great gesture
of something talking about the Grinch if
she doesn't like the Grinch because she
had like that yeah the Grinch
Oh green eggs and ham you guys can't
test me on this stuff okay
green eggs and ham guy okay I know what
you're saying now see it I see what you
say it's not the Grinch for green eggs
no no but I see you but they have a
similar feature so yeah I think the
Grinch the Grinch
he's like the nicer cousin of the Grinch
yeah say no they wanna chill went
straight to Mexico Pass America I go
stream that's a long road trip what do
they do
exactly
they like still like nail polish you
don't tell me their crime
yeah that garlic Crimea's [ __ ] though so
they escaped jail and try to escape
again so ironic maybe they get off on
escapes oh yeah turns me on
hey we just escaped real Jail let's see
if we can escape fake jail yeah yeah
like giulio things we wanted to testers
they want to practice yeah you know
what's a pretty safe place to go to a
ginger bond like a few bounce because
then you know you go to a ginger bond
you gotta be naked I don't know if they
would just let cops walk through the NAB
those dark rooms you could just slowly
hide from the clay room to the other
room getting massaged and just slowly
bounce around those clay B rooms where
would you escape like when they come I
don't know but I was just thinking we'll
go in the sewer there's like a ninja
turtle yeah I was thinking the pool
that's why I would get caught and you'd
get away I just go underwater I thought
you guys are gonna leave [ __ ] you gotta
go in there with a straw if you're doing
a video oh my god these are like some
cartoon [ __ ] solutions as [ __ ] when I
escaped I gotta get a big stick with the
red bag around it that's when you run
away stupid well they're running away
from their troubles hope you guys
enjoyed that episode of JK news make
sure to stay connected because we're
constantly updating our social media so
follow us at JK films for Instagram and
at JK films for Twitter to watch more
videos click right over here
[Music]